SEAN LOPP: Hi, my
name's Sean, I'm
a product manager of RStudio.
As a product manager,
I get to talk
to data science teams both small
and large, all over the world.
And unfortunately in
interacting with these teams,
we often hear that they're
confronted by a false choice
to either pick R or Python.
This choice might
occur when they're
writing a job description to
hire a new data scientist.
It might occur
when they're trying
to decide what to learn
as individuals who
want to up skill
themselves or it
might occur when
they're interacting
with IT asking for resources
to support a project.
So why do teams face
this false choice?
Do we really need to
pick between one language
or another?
The answer is no and today
we're going to talk about why.
We're going to look at some
of the common myths that
lead to this choice.
How to debunk those myths.
And ultimately, how
data science teams
can be most effective
when they choose
to use R and Python together.
Now to set some context,
imagine you're a craftsman.
Someone who is handy
and builds things.
As a craftsman, you're probably
familiar with screwdrivers,
I mean, who hasn't
used the screwdriver
to put something together.
And you might be aware
that screwdrivers
come in a variety of
different shapes and forms.
You can have a flat
head screwdriver, a star
bit, a Phillips head, and
each of these screwdrivers
is designed to serve
a specific purpose.
Now imagine as a
craftsman, if you
were told that
you have to choose
for the rest of your
career between using one
type of screwdriver or another.
You'd probably look at that
person and say, that's crazy,
there's no way I can
practically make this choice.
For some projects I'm going
to need the flat head,
for other projects
I need the Phillips.
It doesn't make sense for me
to pick one screwdriver to use
for the rest of my career.
Instead what you might do
as a craftsman is to say,
I want to opt in to
using a smarter tool.
A tool that's going
to be more powerful
and allow me to take advantage
of all these different bits
that are out there.
Specifically as a
craftsman, you might
be interested in
something like a drill.
A tool that
regardless of what bit
you're going to
need for a project,
allows you to work faster
and accomplish more.
And allows you to work
in an easier fashion.
So craftsmen have this drill.
What about data science teams?
Well, I believe
as data scientists
we should refuse that same
false choice between R
and Python and
other languages just
as the craftsman refuses to
pick one type of screwdriver.
Instead, we should work
alongside of folks in IT
and the leaders of our teams to
build something like a drill.
Something that regardless
of what language we use
is going to give us
the power to accomplish
our projects faster and easier.
So what is that drill
for data science?
We'll take a look
at that in a second.
But first, I want to address
some of these common objections
that you'll hear.
People that say,
no, no, no, there's
no such thing as a
drill for data science.
We have to pick
a single language
or a single screwdriver.
So where do these
objections come from?
What's the biggest objection
that data science teams face?
Well the first one
is this belief,
that if we are to support
more than one language
we'll end up doing a
lot of duplicative work.
So for example, if I were a team
that wanted to use R &amp; Python
IT might be worried that now I
have 2 times the amount of work
to do.
Instead of supporting
one language,
I now have to support
two, that means
twice the number
of installs, twice
the number of support
tickets, twice
the money spent on IT resources.
And luckily, this line of
thinking simply isn't accurate.
And the reason for that is
because regardless of what
language you use, the core
things that IT needs to support
are the same.
Things like computation, logs,
authentication, security, data
access, these provide
a common core,
that drill, that we can invest in
regardless of which drill bit,
which language we end up using.
And so I want to show
you some of those tools
that we've worked on
in RStudio to make
that type of
underlying investment,
that core of data science
infrastructure accessible.
So the first thing I
want to take a look at
is in the development space.
When we're data
scientists going to write
code either R or Python,
often what we want
is to choose an editor
that's purpose built
for one of those languages.
So in R that might
be the RStudio IDE,
in Python that might be
something like a Jupyter
Notebook or more recently
JupyterLabs or perhaps,
I want to use a
full-fledged development
environment like VS code.
Now IT might be
thinking, Oh, no,
that means we have to support
all these different editors,
all these different
environments.
But luckily, that's not true.
With tools like
RStudio Server Pro
you can install a single
infrastructure that supports
those different editors.
And so what you're
seeing on the screen here
is the home page
of RStudio Server.
When a data scientist enters
through that common front door,
they're able to pick
the different editors
that they might want to
use for a certain project.
So IT only has to stand
up one server environment.
They only have to do one
set of configuration.
They only have to supply data
access to one common entry
point.
But the data scientist
is still able to use
whatever editor makes the
most sense for their project.
You'll also see here that
we're taking advantage
of Cloud native
tools like Kubernetes
to provide elastic scale
in a Docker backend
to provide explicitly
those dependencies
that we might need
for a project.
So what this all amounts to
is that in development we're
able to get to our
first line of code
really quickly regardless of
what language that line of code
is written in without
doubling the IT headaches.
Now that's development,
what about production?
What about when it
comes time to create
these different artifacts
and share those with others.
Well luckily the
same concept applies.
So at RStudio what
that looks like is
a tool like RStudio Connect.
So RStudio Connect allows
you to deploy a wide variety
of data artifacts
regardless of what language
they're written in.
So for web
applications in R that
might be something like Shiny,
for web applications in Python
that might be something like
Dash, Streamlit, or Bokeh.
But regardless of which of
those engines you choose to use,
RStudio Connect allows
you to quickly deploy them
onto a web server so that
you get a URL that you
can share with others.
Connect takes care of
things like authentication,
security, logging, and scale.
Similarly, if you wanted to
create an API so you have
a model that you want to
expose to other services,
well that exposure
might take place in R
through a package like Plumber
or might take place in Python
through a tool like Flask.
But either way, Connect
provides that common core
infrastructure, that drill.
Finally, the same thing applies
for automated reporting.
So in the Python side that
might be Jupyter Notebooks.
On the R side, it might be
something like R Markdown.
Regardless, again, we're able to
deploy those things to Connect.
And Connect can handle things
like scheduling those notebooks
to be re-rendered
on a regular basis,
emailing stakeholders
with the new results,
and even customizing
those emails
so that you can send
exactly what you
need to a stakeholders inbox
regardless of what language
you're using for a project.
Again, IT is only setting
up this infrastructure once.
They're not doubling their
work just because you're
multiplying by 5 or 10-fold
the number of different data
products that you can use.
As a data scientist
that flexibility is key
when it comes to
communicating your work,
getting buy-in to the
modeling that you're doing,
or working alongside of a
domain expert in real time
in a meeting, you need
to have the flexibility
to use all these different tools
to be effective data science
team.
And so that's what we're setting
out to do is to build products,
build those drills that allow
you regardless of drill bit
to effectively
communicate your work.
And so because this
is so important,
because it is the
most common myth,
I want to spend just
a little bit more time
looking at that common core.
And so this diagram
hopefully shows you
what I've been talking about.
Where we have these
layers that are
going to be the same regardless
of what language we're using.
So those layers are things
like common authentication,
things like logging,
things like scaling.
And then the final layer,
the choice of R or Python
is ultimately a
last mile effort.
So we're not multiplying
our work by two,
we're actually only changing
that final top piece.
Now I showed you RStudio Server Pro
and RStudio Connect as one way
to implement this
drill but teams
can implement the drill
in other ways as well.
For example, some organizations
will use a Cloud provider.
Some organizations will
use something like Docker.
Regardless, the key
concept is that you
build those common paradigms
that your data scientist
regardless of
language or package
is going to be able
to take advantage of.
And once you debunk that
myth, that more languages mean
more problems, you're
well on your way
to those multiplicative efforts
to avoiding that false choice
and having a lot more options
to build what you need
to build to get the job done.
So that's that first myth
hopefully now debunked.
Let's talk about a
second one, which
is that multilingual
teams can't collaborate.
Imagine you are a data
science team leader
and you have three or four
data scientists on your team
that have built out something
really awesome in Python.
In fact, I was speaking
to a data science team
leader named Wayne recently who
was exactly in this situation.
But he needed to
hire someone new,
in his context was
a marketing project,
he really wanted to hire
someone with marketing domain
knowledge.
But unfortunately, he
couldn't find that candidate
who had both the Python
expertise and the marketing
background.
But he did know a few people
who had strong marketing chops
and knew a little bit of R.
Is he presented with
a false choice here?
I think so, because it turns out
that even if your code base is
mostly in Python you
can bring someone
who has a background in R
up to speed really quickly.
And again, it comes
down to having
those right tools
a common drill bit
to allow for that type of
inter team collaboration.
And so I want to
quickly show you
what investments
we've made in RStudio
to make that type of
collaboration possible.
So what we're looking at
here is the RStudio IDE.
In the new version of the
IDE has a what you see
is what you mean
editor for R Markdown.
Inside of that editor,
you're able to incorporate
both R and Python code chunks.
So here, you're
looking at Python code
that we're able to
run but that code
takes advantage
of objects coming
from R. See the r.cars object.
So once we have that
Python code executed,
it's actually going
to write objects back
into the environment that
we can see in the IDE.
So in the environment
pane in objects explorer,
we can view that panda's
data frame we created.
Once we're happy with the
result that we have in Python,
we can use the what you
see is what you mean editor
to insert an R code chunk that
takes advantage of that Python
data frame.
So just like we used
the R object in Python,
we can use the
Python object in R
and create a plot with
ggplot2 of that Python data.
Now this interoperability
extends beyond R Markdown
through the reticulate package.
So here, we have a
Shiny application
that's going to take
a Python function
and actually source it and
make it available to the R
engine without any conversion.
It's pretty magical.
We can then call that Python
function inside of our Shiny
app that allows us to build
something like this, which
is a shiny application where
the front end of the input
and controls are driven by Shiny
but the back end simulation
is occurring in those
Python functions.
So we're able, as a
multilingual team to really glue
these two things together.
Whether we're
bilingual or not, we
can take advantage of a code
base written in either language
to achieve a really
unique outcome.
And that's what debunking these
false choices is all about.
It's finding ways to
combine the strengths,
the best of both languages as
well as the best of our team
to come together to create
something faster and easier
than we could if
we were in isolated
silos with either language.
And that leads me
to my final point,
which is that we need as
data scientists to optimize
for people not for tools.
Well what do I mean by that.
Let's think about the
story of Wayne trying
to hire as it
turned out her name
was Vicky, a data scientist
coming from the R space instead
of the Python background.
Because Wayne was able to set
aside the distinction in tools,
he could come up with a data
science team that together
was more effective than
if he had limited his job
criteria to only people
that knew Python.
And so we see that story play
out time and time again.
At the end of the day when
we talk to data science team
leaders, their most important
asset and their most expensive
isn't a particular
tool or platform,
it's the data scientist
that they're hiring
to solve complex problems.
In another way, one of the
big reasons organizations
invest in data science
in the first place
is because Blackbox solutions
like Tableau or PowerBI
simply don't meet the needs
of the Rich complex real world
problems that they're facing.
So why would it make any sense
for those same data science
teams that have recognized
they need the flexibility
and power of code to achieve
outcomes to then sabotage
themselves by
limiting themselves
to only one language.
It simply doesn't,
it's a false choice.
And so today, my final plea
is to pick the people that
will make your data
science team effective
and then supply them
with what they need.
Don't make people
subservient to tools,
it should be the
other way around.
Allow data science teams
to pick whatever language
or tools can be most effective.
And help you do that
at RStudio, we've
invested in building out
drills so that regardless
of what drillbit you need you
can effectively build something
faster and easier.
Thank you so much for your
time and I look forward
to your questions.